we had a look at triangles which there's
lots of patterns we looked at
i'm looking at it by angle looking by
side and so we're moving forward from
triangles
into quadrilaterals there are lots of
really cool interesting things about
quadratics so
if you want to make in your top left
hand corner a little heavy
which is quadrilateral and i'm going to
be
well you guys know i have a picture for
somewhat cheesy days
so this morning we're going to call it
quadrilateral evolution because that's
what we're going to
see quadrilaterals do or they can't do
anyway right
so again we're going to draw a series of
shapes and it's going to be enormously
helpful if you use your ruler for these
also even though my board is much wider
than your page
i'm going to position things as if i
were using your page okay
so for example this first shape i'm
going to draw i'm going to draw it right
in the middle
of my sideways page in the middle here
not at the top and that there's a reason
for that
it'll all look a lot better if we try
and keep it reasonably consistent
okay so quite a little evolution
um what we talk about like organisms
that evolve
right what does that generally mean like
this but yeah
fantastic they change over time
generally why do organisms
change like yeah fantastic to adapt to
their environment they get like extra
features
that help them survive better right and
generally we talk about
animals like yeah when we say evolving
we don't need getting worse
we mean that they're getting core and
you know getting features
or attributes that are useful right so
we're going to do to do that
quadrilaterals evolving we're just going
to start with the basic
nothing special about it
there we go that's uh that'll have to do
this is a quadrilateral and there's
literally
nothing special about it no equal signs
no equal angles
it's just a quadrilateral
okay so it's a quadrilateral and it's
important that you know when we say
quadrilateral
rather than some other name what we mean
is it has no special properties
all it has is the one defining property
that all quadrilaterals have
which is for science because that's what
contralateral
means right no special properties it
just has
four sides okay so with event evolution
here right
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
take our standard
boring old quadrilateral and i'm going
to think about what happens
if we add on
some different kinds of properties some
different kinds of attributes
okay so for instance if i take my
quadrilateral
and it evolves it adds on
a pair of
parallel sides just a single pair by the
way i'm going to ask lots of questions
today
um please raise your hand as you're
answering so we get some good
participation from everyone
if you have a quadrilateral and all you
do is add a
single pair of sides that go in the same
direction
what kind of shape are we going to get
yeah
whoa okay we're going to get to the
robust but that's a fair way away
before we get to that like all i've got
this is all i've got tinder you're going
to have shut up
trapezium very good okay so let's draw a
trapezium together
um i'm going to draw something like this
because we will get to
we will get to the problems so you can
see
here i've drawn it such that you've got
a parallel side and here
and that's what makes it a trapezium
all it's got is those parallel sides
right um you might notice there's these
non-parallel sides here sometimes
they're equal but they don't have to be
all i've added on is a pair of parallel
sides so that's it
that's a standard trapezium okay
all right now from our quadrant i'll
come back to it
there's something else we could add
which is also pretty basic but instead
of like
parallel which is about direction i want
to think about changing some of the
lengths right so yeah
yeah did you want to ask something okay
we'll yes we will get to the right angle
it's a bit
further it's a little more specialized
right angles are pretty cool before we
get to that
one other thing we could add is not a
pair of parallel sides
but two pairs
of equal sides now when we say equal
or with intermediates is same length
right so they're the same distance from
from corner to corner right
so if you take a quadrilateral and
you've got
two pairs of equal sides like
two equal up here and two equal down
here what do we call that kind of
shape two equal up here and two equal
down here
we usually call that a kite right so i'm
going to draw one
here like so
there's this one perimeter side
and here's another pair and you can see
why it gets called a kite
okay now i put these arrows on to
indicate that they're parallel
how do i indicate when sites are equal
to each other what do i put on there
someone who hasn't said anything
yeah yeah good a dash but rather than
like
as an arrow i just put a dash like that
so those are equal
these two are equal to each other but
they're not equal to the original pair
so i'll put
two dashes cool there we go
i've got my kite
so i've got two evolutions two evolved
versions of the quadrilateral and
they're both more special
they've both got more properties than
the original
okay but i can keep going i can go keep
going much further
right for instance let's think about
this guy
you put it you're ready stay first
if i've added one pair of parallel sides
then a natural
next step in evolution instead of having
just one pair
is to have two pairs because i've got
four sides to play with right so from
here
right i'm going to add
a second pair
of parallel sides
okay so being that i've got two pairs of
parallel sides
what shape do i have now
parallel parallel jordan whoa okay i've
got to get to the rectangular square but
they're even
more special they're like way further
along i haven't got there yet
josh now we go parallel very good it's
kind of named after
the property that it's got right so i'm
going to draw it again here in the
middle
okay so like this so there's one pair of
parallel sides
very good josh and just like before see
how there's one marker and then two
markers to get the other two i'll put
two arrows
okay so by the way just like the word
isosceles
parallelogram oh i forgot to name the
kite
a parallelogram is very easy to misspell
okay so it's parallel
just like the normal word and then oh
graham
parallelogram it's exactly the way
it sounds okay now just before we leave
off the parallelogram right
jupiter i said we're kind of like we're
kind of adding extra properties as we go
right one of the interesting things you
might notice is that
when you make the second pair of sides
parallel if you've drawn yours with a
ruler and you've made it like pretty
parallel you can see you haven't just
gotten parallel science
you've got something else for free yeah
very good heard there
you also have the parallel sides now
suddenly
by no choice like they have to be equal
as well
yeah so i've got equal sides here
right and i've also got equal sides
here now you will notice it's it's quite
similar to the kind
right can you see it similar to the kite
again you've got two pairs of equal
sides
but they're arranged a little bit
differently can you see
here the equal sides are they they're
facing each other they're opposite right
bless you but here the equal sides are
they're next to each other we have a
word a fancy word that starts with a
that means adjacent very good so
adjacent equal sides
opposite equal sides okay cool